so yesterday after the news broke that
carson wentz got what he wanted to trade
out of philadelphia quincy avery the
personal quarterbacks coach of deshaun
watson the starting quarterback of the
texans if you haven't heard ask this on
twitter what's the criteria for a
quarterback asking to get traded then
actually getting traded asking for a
friend i think that's the first time
that the phrase asking for a friend when
used on twitter
actually was
asking for a friend miles
yeah he wasn't actually just asking for
himself he wanted to know for his friend
deshawn watson the first thing i thought
when i saw that was man how does desean
watson feel about this now being public
i mean because even you know we all know
i think what's been reported and what's
going on there and the relationship is
clearly fractured between uh watson and
the texans but that's
it's
it's not usually that direct you know
where it's asking for a friend and you
know that who the friend actually is
yeah and look
i don't know where any of this is going
to go because i can't predict how the
texans will handle their business i
think their best play
would be to go to deshaun watson and say
we know you have no trade clause give us
a list of teams you play for and then
start now
getting teams to the table let's get
your best offers on the table and keep
letting them work against each other and
bid their way to something that would be
a great return for desean watson if that
if they are going to as it appears
digging their heels and say we're not
trading him we're not trading him and
he's going to hold out and stay away and
they do like they did with dwayne brown
in 2017 where you know they trade him
right before the trade who you what are
you going to get what kind of value are
you going to get
when there's no one left now who knows
maybe deshawn watson is so good that a
team will upend its plans mid-season if
it has to to get to sean watson but this
is not the way to get the absolute best
and complete trade package for deshawn
watson and i think miles at some point
desean watson and and i i credit him for
being discreet and quiet and not taking
this public i think at some point he has
to i think they're forcing him to
sit down for an interview do something
where he's got to say in his own voice
and he's got to explain why this just
isn't working anymore and he wants to
move on i think he very much would like
to avoid having to do that it may be
that at some point he has to do it in
order to get the message out and in
order to get the texans to realize there
is a downside to dragging their feet on
this that he is going to take it public
that he is going to take the fight to
them
and maybe he's in the process now of
just giving them every chance to do it
the right way before he takes it into a
public forum
well i think that first of all for the
texans there's no better time to trade
him than right now i don't think his
desean watson's value is ever going to
be as high as it is right now so if
you're talking about maximizing what you
can get out of this trade desean watson
could go for an unprecedented amount of
first round picks of draft picks and you
could add in some other players as well
because you know he is a franchise
quarterback who can play at an elite
level and those guys just don't ever
come on the market basically ever so i
think from that perspective if you're
gonna do this and if you know if you're
the texans and you know that desean
watson is disgruntled he doesn't want to
play for you anymore he has made that
very clear behind the scenes there's
only i think one good way of get going
about this and the way that most
benefits the texans is to trade him
right now when his value is at its
highest especially because as time
passes teams will be making their
arrangements already off the board the
rams and the lions and the eagles and
the cults although the eagles can still
be in play i don't think that they will
make a move for deshaun watson but the
cults aren't going to and the rams
aren't going to and the lions aren't
going to and those are teams that
potentially could have been in the mix
if
the
texans had been committed to this
strategy of let's start the bidding
let's get an auction going and let's see
where we go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports